elle est devenue la bête noire des
républicains depuis qu'elle a osé s'en
prendre à d'autres chantent en route
vers le bureau de vote elle met en garde
les américains à adma a causé la
démocratie est attaqués menacés dit-elle
de bolivie point une feuille donnent
tous ceux qui croient en la liberté
doivent mettre leur valeur au dessus de
la partisanerie politique avec un beau
gâchis
et
c'est ce qu'elle a fait lorsque les
partisans de dans notre chambre
envahissent le capitole le 6 janvier car
ils ne reconnaissent pas le résultat des
élections c'est la rupture
dans notre homme a fait le choix de
violer le serment qu'il a prêté en tant
que président dit and poor's elle vote
deux fois pour sa mise en accusation
coup préside la commission denquête du 6
janvier à mannheim elle est alors en
péril son siège de représentante
républicaine du wyoming selon elle le
risque en vaut la chandelle
après tout il s'agit de la constitution
du pays un sentiment que ne partagent
pas beaucoup d'électeurs républicain du
wyoming qui se porte à la défense de
notre homme
mineur
jean jacques ory elle est en train
d'endommager le pays dit il il ya trop
de drames et immédiate
à l'etrat guen est la nouvelle
coqueluche des républicains et surtout
dans notre chambre elle est devenue son
porte-voix wyoming
absolument ces élections ont été volés
dit elle
pourtant 2016 elle était l'une des plus
fervents supporters de lille chez ni ses
preuves entre jazz aujourd'hui elle et
sa rivale eva remporter la mise news
corp
est un lâche ddcs szczesny car il ment à
ses électeurs des bornes en 246 ans
d'histoire il est la plus grande menace
à notre république mais peu importe les
avertissements jobs demeure très
populaire au wyoming un état qui l'a
remporté avec 70 % des voix en 2020
nous nous battons contre le mal dit adam
key zenger qui ne se représentera pas
aux primaires comme les chaînes il a
reçu des menaces de mort pour s'être
opposée dans nos champs nommé à la boîte
et à connaître quels que soient les
résultats dit elle c'est le début d'une
longue bataille car nous faisons face à
des temps difficiles